on the hill tonight
for the giants making start number one
caleb berger
berger is five and one with a four five
eight era 15 strikeouts uh against five
walks at 19 and two thirds 68 degrees
here in san francisco in the 01
and tapia drills one to dickerson who
moves back and that's how this game gets
started
so here's trevor's story
popped up to either belt or duggar
duggar sees where belt is now he calls
him off and he makes the catch brian
castellani has kind of been an up and
down freshman season if you will but out
on the road he's been good now here's
alex dickerson 1-0 pitch swing and
there's a high pop-up the shortstop
story behind second now the wind starts
to carry it behind him and it drops into
shallow center field
he was on the infield dirt near second
base
then he started to backpedal and then
suddenly he started to panic crawford
comes up with two men on and two men out
not a whole lot of speed on the bases
here
one two is tap slowly towards second
hamson over to fuentes good job by ryan
castellani it's the left-handed swinging
charlie blackman this ball's lined to uh
the corner
and charlie's going to get a double out
of it charlie likes facing berger i was
going to say you got to figure this will
be it for barry gerthy berger out logan
webb in the rockies have men on the
corners now with two outs for sam
hilliard there you have it there's a
swing ground ball to second solano over
to his right gets it straightens up
fires to first in time for the out bring
up rymel tapia topping a flight out to
left his first time up his next pitch is
swung on and dribbled to the left side
longoria charges bare hands throws but
not in time tapia beats that out dory
with a chance with a man in scoring
position this is lie to center field
base hit topia route third here's the
throw toward the plate not going to get
rivelle
and it's one nothing rockies on the base
hit by story not easy to elevate a ball
against webb so when you get a pitch
that allows you to do that you need to
make connections
the giants so need him to lock it back
in he is over his last 16.
longoria into center field pallar back
palar at the wall
out of here
and longoria ties the game his seventh
of the year
and the longoria fan cam right now
they're going nuts
well
[Applause]
thinking i threw one curveball too many
another curveball with some hang
and how strong are those hands
so here's joey bart the catcher in the
eight hole the 2-2 pitch is a pop-up way
up there third base side mcmahon coming
over into the coaches box he overran it
makes a dive to his left and he caught
it ryan mcmahon the win pushed that one
like it did a pop-up in the first inning
that story couldn't handle
and that turned into it looked like a
totally routine play it turned into a
highlight play a one-out single for
garrett hampson lead off man rymel tapia
and this ball is lying to deep left and
it's over the head at dickerson he
misjudged it hamson to third he's coming
home the throw to the plate not gonna
get him rockies go ahead two to one
two to one rocky's lead stickers to the
hitter one for two in the game
dickerson down the right field line is
this fair you bet it is it's in the
corner
blackman will dig it out and dickerson's
gonna go into second base with a double
first and third one out in the inning
crawford has grounded out to second
crawford hits one high to pilar in
center field with dickerson tagging
and this is going to tie the game so a
nice at-bat from brandon crawford that's
great
dubai he'll be the first one to face
almante two on two out
high drive to left looking back is
hillyard
out of here
and the giants take the lead on mauricio
duvon's third home run of the year
he sat long enough next to longoria in
the dugout to figure it out
well and i think what he
he learned from
longoria is look breaking ball kid
they're throwing a bunch of them tonight
and that folks is on a tee all right new
pitcher tommy doyle making his major
league debut that's how he did last year
in a ball 48 strikeouts in 36 innings
mark's over three
line shot into right center field and
charlie blackman can't cut it off in
park may have himself a triple he is
digging to third and he's gonna make it
standing
here's duggar and duggar flips one into
left and coming in and having to get off
his glove as hilliard and coming in to
score is joey bart and duggar with an
rbi single so here's bell runners at the
corners
and he shoots this one into right field
of base hit
he knocks it right through the shift and
he's got a single in an rbi how about
that he's been on base
five times today
elias diaz will lead off against selman
this is sky to left for dickerson
this is the highest ball hit tonight and
it's out number one
got him three breaker balls good morning
good afternoon and thanks for stopping
by here's hampton
lifted to
duggar
and that's the ball game game
three in this four game series it goes
to the giants